quit your job and go start it yes there
are characteristics for people who are
good at entrepreneurs they quit their
job and they go start it I'm sit next to
a lovely woman once and she had a
fantastic idea for for a company and so
how long you been like designing it and
whatnot she'd said 18 months I said well
okay give you a bit a bit of advice you
know yeah put down your fork and knife
leave breakfast go to your office lock
the door thur your three colleagues
nobody's allowed to leave the room you
have to order in pizza and beer and soda
and whatever else it is until you finish
the product dance life if you don't do
that you will never be successful if you
do it you have a shot right you have a
shot to fail which is you know that's a
that's a better starting point then
never even have a shot to to fail so she
didn't do it somebody else along a
couple other companies launched the same
product she actually never got out the
out the door so if you want to be an
entrepreneur quit your job right now
shut down this browser after you
patronize big thanks advertisers first
and go start it now
why are you still looking at me go start
it now